my guide to buying the finest shellfish
whether it's scallops prawns crabs or
lobster
spanking fresh shellfish never fails to
make an impression
and when you want the best crustaceans
it pays to ask an expert
19 pound it's a bargain at 20 pounds
fishmonger roger barton
really knows his shellfish inside out
hello
he said can he go back home so i'm sorry
brother you're with me
he's been in the fish game at london's
billings gate market for over 35 years
glean some of his knowledge and you'll
never be at a loss when it comes to
shopping
for shellfish
right what we've got here are corvettes
some people known as prawns
and these are a picture they've got to
be lovely and shiny
you'll find if they're too limp the head
starts coming away from the body
not a good sign looks a bit like me
worse for the whale
chop your old garlic up get the old wok
lovely
bit of olive oil lovely lovely jubbly
lovely lovely jubilee
in they go absolutely fantastic
and if you like prawns as much as me
then you'll love all these different
kinds
here are my favorites brown shrimps
might be tiny but punch well above their
weight in terms of taste
i love them potted in spice butter and
spread on toast
atlantic prawns are great value and
packed with flavor
fantastic as tapas or in curries
small tiger prawns are also good value
and great for asian salads stir fries
and fish stews
whereas these massive ones are so
spectacular i just keep them simple
marinated in garlic oil and chili char
grilled and
served in their shells and longustings
are one of my favorites you can buy the
succulent beauties whole
just roast or boil and serve with garlic
mayonnaise
[Music]
people used to eat winkles goggles
they're not doing it anymore it's such a
shame
they should be more daring all due
respect you wouldn't make love the same
way
for the rest of your fat life wrinkles
there they are lovely they smell of the
seed
a little bit of pepper and salt and a
dash of vinegar then that does enhance
the flavor
in this country we have got the finest
oysters in the world
i die for these the only thing you have
to look for with an oyster that is
tightly closed
if it's open avoid
be adventurous come on try it
nothing ventured nothing going get the
right recipe and the freshest shellfish
and you'll guarantee success in the
kitchen
whether it's in one of my restaurants or
back at home i know
that as well as delicious food one of
the fundamentals to making guests happy
is creating a great atmosphere
vietnamese style
fresh prawn rolls one of the keys to
cooking for crowds is
creating the atmosphere and that buzz
getting your guests to sort of
almost get involved and dip in and dip
out
this is an exciting fragrant wrap
that is so easy to do
first off soak the noodles these are
thin
glass noodles basically bring the kettle
up to the boil
and just pour just let them steep there
for a couple of minutes
the noodles are for my prawn rolls as
they soak i'm gonna make a spicy dipping
sauce to go with them
start off with sugar we're trying to
create that sweet
sour salty but a really nice sort of
heated sauce as well rice wine vinegar
that will dissolve the sugar
fish sauce now that's going to give it
saltiness
next the chili i want the seeds left in
because i want some power
chilli in a little bit of garlic
don't need to chop it too finely just
slice it
take a spring onion just top and tail
them
slice the slices bring it in nice and
thinly so it sort of
almost permeates that dipping sauce i
grew up with the love of spring rolls
but
on the back of my visit to vietnam it
sort of transformed my respect for a
spring roll
give that a little mix a little bit of
coriander
and fresh mint roll them up and chop
herbs in there's no olive oil in there
there's no cream there's no butter it's
just a really nice light
dipping sauce and wow all those senses
going on
now we're gonna make the filling for the
wraps a really nice
fresh noodle salad rinse the noodles in
cold water
then chop them into bite-sized lengths
prawns peeled and cooked slice them up
the prawns give a really nice sweetness
next
the vegetables i want crunch freshness
texture baby gem lettuce and just shred
that lettuce
next spring onion the good news about
these wraps is that you can make them up
in advance
sit them in the fridge and then take
them out literally seconds
before you guess arrive peel the carrot
so you got really nice fresh crunchy
carrot
now fresh mint fresh basil and fresh
coriander
together it sounds a little bit bizarre
but it tastes amazing
don't hold back with the herbs they'll
really help make the filling vibrant
fresh
and aromatic finally touch a lime
just squeeze that fresh lime juice over
there
a couple of tablespoons of your dipping
sauce
don't put too much in there it just
makes all the filling too wet
just give that a really good mix that's
a very quick simple salad to eat now but
let's get it into a wrap now take your
rice paper wrap
literally 30 seconds in warm water
you can get rice paper wraps from your
local asian supermarket or buy them
online
gently lift it out the water there
beautiful
lay it carefully onto your board
[Music]
place the mixture at the bottom
don't overfill it because it'll be a
nightmare to roll
fold them over first nice and tightly
halfway then tuck in the ends
make sure nothing's coming out the sides
beautiful it's so light
fragrant incredibly simple to do
and there you go a very delicious
fragrant
asian wrap certainly different to the
chinese spring rolls
i grew up with
to prep it get the head and twist
keep hold of those heads make the most
amazing stock and then with your thumb
get underneath the shell and just peel
off that beautiful little layer
now with your thumb on your finger push
and shake
and look the whole tail comes off you
don't have to peel the whole thing
from there get your knife
and just gently cut the surface of the
prawn
and what we're looking for there is that
little dirt sack that's got to come out
otherwise if you cook the prawn with
that sack in there it's crunchy
it's not very nice and it ruins that
sweet flavor and there you go
the most amazing prawn ready for cooking